if you have kids in elementary school
you'll want to know about a new school
that aims to revolutionize the idea of
what's possible in public education
joining me now is carly casto the
founding principal at cactus park
elementary welcome
well congratulations on this new school
enrollment is now open
tell us a little bit about cactus park
elementary and what makes it different
than other elementary schools yeah so
there's a couple things that make us
different for one we are a free public
charter school
so we are separate from our school
district but we're still a public school
and then the next thing is our model
that makes us different so our model is
focused on three main things
that's uh civic engagement
social identity development and academic
excellence and what we found is when you
focus on those first couple things it
helps with that academic side and that
is something that is often ignored
especially kids that age that's really a
great thing and you you see the
improvement in academics when you kind
of take a look at those other two things
huh yes for sure that's great so tell us
about
applying can anyone apply to the school
yeah so
anybody can apply it's open enrollment
okay um it's and like i said it's free
public school so
we're enrolling right now grades k
through four and that's the grades we'll
have in year one okay in year two we'll
add fifth grade so that will be a full
k through five elementary now
it doesn't matter what part of the
valley you live in where is the school
actually located so we're located on las
vegas boulevard and pecos so kind of
northeast part of the valley okay and
yeah you can live anywhere and apply you
just have to be a clark county resident
now do you offer enrichment services for
families that may need some a little
extra help absolutely so you know we're
going to have a food pantry on site for
families
also a big focus on mental health and
wrap around services not only for
families not only for students but also
for the adults that work with us to make
sure that you know everybody's wellness
is being centered it really does sound
like you've got all of the bases covered
here now again anyone can apply how do
they do that for open enrollment yeah so
you can apply by going to our website
it's pilotednevada.org
uh all you do is you can click on the
link that says enroll here you just fill
out a quick application and that's all
it takes it sounds like an amazing
school and you can be one of the first
students to go there and have your kids
attend so that is very cool thank you so
much for telling us about that and